Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
cette première vidéo de “Science Étonnante”.
Aujourd'hui je voudrais vous raconter
pourquoi dans n'importe quel verre d'eau,
on peut toujours trouver
des molécules qui, dans le passé,
ont déjà été bues par Jules César !
[ Générique ]
Alors voilà, j'ai avec moi un verre d'eau
et vous savez que l'eau est faite
de molécules d'eau H2O,
deux atomes d'hydrogène et un atome d'oxygène.
Alors il faut savoir qu'une molécule d'eau
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très très petit,
puisque ça fait à peu près 0,3 nanomètre.
Ça veut dire que c'est plus petit
qu'un millionième de millimètre.
Ce n'est pas vraiment très très simple de se représenter
ce que veulent dire des tailles aussi petites
donc une autre manière d'y penser est de se demander:
« Finalement, dans un verre d'eau, comme celui là,
combien il y a de molécules d'eau? »
En fait, on peut le calculer assez facilement:
on connaît la masse d'une molécule d'eau,
je sais quelle masse d'eau il y a dans mon verre.
Je peux simplement faire la division.
Et si on fait ça, on trouve que
dans un verre d'à peu près 30 centilitres,
il y a environ 10 puissance 25 molécules d'eau.
Donc, 10 puissance 25, c'est vraiment un chiffre astronomique, c'est 1 suivi de 25 zéros !
Par exemple, c'est plus que
le nombre degrainsdesablesurTerre!
Et tout ça, juste dans mon verre d'eau.
Alors maintenant, je voudrais
qu'on s'intéresse à JulesCésar
et en particulier au dernier verre qu'il a bu
juste avant de se faire assassiner.
Ce dernier verre, s'il était à peu près comme le mien,
il contenait, lui aussi, 10 puissance 25 molécules d'eau.
La question que je me pose aujourd'hui, c'est:
parmi ces 10 puissance 25 molécules
qui étaient dans le dernier verre de César,
est-ce que, par chance, il n'y en aurait pas une
qui se trouverait là, aujourd'hui, dans mon verre à moi?
Alors, en fait, pour estimer ça,
on va supposer que toutes les molécules
qui étaient dans le dernier verre de César,
aujourd'hui, elles sont complètement
répandues sur la planète.
Ce n'est pas complètement absurde de penser cela
parce qu'il y a le cycle de l'eau,
les précipitations, les courants marins
et ça s'est quand même passé il y a 2000 ans.
Donc on va supposer que toutes
ces molécules du dernier verre de César,
aujourd'hui, elles sont complètement
diluées dans les eaux de la planète.
Mais quelle quantité d'eau y a-t-il sur la planète?
C'est assez simple à calculer.
Je ne vais pas vous surprendre en disant que
la quasi-totalité de l'eau de la planète
c'est les mers et les océans.
Et on sait que les mers et océans
font en moyenne 4~5km de profondeur
et couvrent 70% de la surface du globe.
Donc si on fait le calcul,
on trouve que sur Terre il y a à peu près
10 puissance 21 litres d'eau.
10 puissance 21 litres,
c'est mille milliards de milliards de litres.
Sauf que tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que
dans le dernier verre de César,
il y avait 10 puissance 25 molécules d'eau.
Donc si on suppose que ces
10 puissance 25 molécules d'eau
sont aujourd'hui complètement diluées
dans toute l'eau de la planète,
je peux calculer que, en moyenne,
dans chaque litre d'eau de la planète,
il y a environ 10000 molécules qui se trouvaient
dans le dernier verre de César.
10000 molécules par litre d'eau,
ça veut dire que dans mon verre à moi
qui fait 20~30 centilitres,
il y aurait à peu près 2000 à 3000 molécules
qui se trouvaient déjà dans le dernier verre de César.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi, ça me bluffe!
Évidemment, le raisonnement n'est pas du tout
spécifique au dernier verre de César,
j'aurais très bien pu prendre
l'avant-dernier verre, son millième verre
ou même son premier biberon, c'était pareil!
Évidemment ça marche aussi avec Louis XIV, Napoléon.
Ça marche même avec le dernier verre de Jésus.
Voilà j'espère que maintenant que vous savez cela,
vous regarderez vos verres d'eau
d'un autre œil, juste avant de les boire,
en pensant à tous les grands hommes
du passé quis'y trouvent!
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu.
Sachez que vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne.
C'est la première vidéo mais il y en aura d'autres.
Vous pouvez me retrouver sur mon blog “Science étonnante”
ainsi que sur Facebook et sur Twitter. À bientôt!